these days technology is evolving so
rapidly that keeping yourself up to date
is almost mandatory that's why I look
into simply learns professional
certificate program in data Engineering
in partnership with purview University
and IBM with this I was able to crack a
new job with a salary hike after the
completion of the course hey I'm Nathan
Jimenez campus I live in Costa Rica and
I'm currently working as a system
analyst at a multinational
pharmaceutical company my professional
life has been in the hurricane domain
mostly I'm working for company Center on
patient care through technology and
medical products before taking the
course I built with Technologies like
mes system development QA testing and
databases and so on it's safe to say
that I was pretty good at my job but I
have this hunger and learning new skills
and Technologies in the it domain that's
when I decided to go for simple learn
fictional certificate program in data
Engineering in the partnership with
Purdue University and IBM I really like
it how our structures were industry
experts who had a real life work
experience the 24 7 support and Hands-On
practice Labs were amazing too
but what I liked it most is the learning
about the new technologies such as AWS
Azure Kafka Hadoop and others and
understanding the functional process of
distributed environments was very
interesting and very productive in my
current job I'm working with both AWS as
well as Azure and I'm able to do so only
because of these skills that I acquired
during the course in the near future I
see myself as a professional with
internal knowledge of my company and
business processes related to ID and
also management
that's the reason why I keep training
myself I think that everyone should
constantly upgrade their knowledge base
because technology never stops evolving
keep learning and keep up Skilling